I just want to say beforehand that was
an amazing talk I'm a much more
conversational speaker so it excuse me
if it doesn't measure it up just want to
set expectations beforehand so my name
is star yang I'm data scientist at the
Department of Commerce and today I want
to talk about just a small question that
we face at the primer e-commerce I think
it applies to everybody here who works
in data and hopefully I've been reading
a lot of Taoism and Confucianism
recently so hopefully posing this
question will all find enlightenment at
the end of this but don't chase me out
of the room if we don't so before we
gets you the actual question some
background just so you know how we came
to this question at the beginning so
like I said I work at the Department of
Commerce that's our lovely seal I'm
actually the first time I actually
looked at it in detail so it's a it's
interesting you sure the front end or UI
designers can come up with something
some improvements potentially but for
people who don't know the Department of
Commerce is a huge huge huge entity it
has 12 agencies within it and you may
know some of them census you know USPTO
but it also includes places like miss
who which is the national standards who
basically define what is one pound for
us it includes noah for the weather
includes all these agencies we're very
diverse and seeming seemingly different
subject matters they're all unified in
one mission which is to grow the economy
and that's why we issue as an entity
called the parma commerce a lot of
public data right that's our vector
towards growing the economy and so if
you were to look at the federal public
open data sets available then complete
listing Department Commerce is roughly a
third
it's roughly a little bit more than a
third so rounding down but it covers a
lot and it's constantly released we have
different release schedules for every
kind of data from daily to monthly to
panel to quarter to annual all of that
is on separate schedules them if we were
to list all of that it is mind-boggling
um and we collected in a number of ways
noah uses satellites and instruments
right senses uses a lot of surveys nist
and bis do a lot to legal and through
standards right all that data is
important for the economy and it affects
everything we do our standards dictate
how your phone is made how your
television works how you organize your
business right so although that is
important all that is important open
data and so it leads to a question I'm
posing to everybody today and that is
how to impart better understanding of
our data at the partner commerce we ask
we ask ourselves this so just a little
insight we release this data publicly
and we our hope is for people to take
this data and grow the economy but what
if they don't know how to use that data
what do they do it wrong and that's
totally a pitfall but our job is to
impart better understanding to them
right making it open does not imply
making it understandable so I think this
applies everybody here who works in data
because in part all of us are building
something off of data right we are
passing something in long some insight
some product some final thing from that
data whether it is another version of
that data and so how do all of us in
part better
of the data to the person we are giving
it to next in line so I like to think of
this is not just a do so you can under
hopefully it is a data conundrum and all
of us can think a little bit about it
I'll promise I have the answer I have a
couple ideas and just so we can frame it
in a little different way a different
perspective so people can have a sort of
the idea of what I'm talking about is
how many people here have just a quick
show of hands have inherited code from
somebody else awesome like it could have
gone two ways no hands we're all hands
I'm glad it went the other way so so
this is the only line of code I wrote
for this presentation which is hopefully
you'll forgive me and it's actually Ron
so like but you can imagine for yourself
all the code even Harry did you see this
function right and you're like what does
this function do no idea no comments
right if it's not common it's not
annotated there's no documentation for
how do you begin working on that
inherited code base and so what I'm
trying to say is that the data we give
is also inherited in the same way code
is inherited data is inherited our open
data sets are inherited anything you
give as a data product is inherited and
so just liven up the room I have a quick
quiz for you about public data in
Department of Commerce how many people
here have used the American Community
Survey oh my god you never know these
things like I've had presentations where
nobody raised a hand I'm like okay just
go into the next one then
so I want to ask the people who have
used American community said it were
people who haven't a little background
american community survey the acs short
is the largest survey in the united
states it might be the largest in the
planet I'm not quite sure because we
have a lot of money it has some 20,000
variables about the American life in
that survey has one year three year five
year vintages it's a massive massive
undertaking surveys three percent of the
population roughly every year that's a
lot of surveys and so they release
aratus when they detect an error whether
in their published data whether in their
data collection or in there any of their
processes right they have to publicly
disclose it for people who use ACS were
people who are interested can anybody
venture a guess how many ratas were
issued in 2016 so far 0 I wish it was 0
um no so somewhere between 0 150 ah so
the answer is actually five there are
five major Aretas issued so far in 2016
and they're pretty major if you go look
at them some of them include just the
wrong number some of them clued wrong
data collection processes some include
all these things right since I like
obscure formats I put a QR code if
people want to get to the website that
lists the Aretas but this is just one of
those things this severely impacts your
final product right if there is an error
there and you do not know about it
ignorance does not protect you from your
final analysis you need to know how do
we convey it better so I've talked about
this I don't know a couple times but
veers nighttime lights is I think an
awesome cool product and
a satellite image of the planet the
nighttime lights on the planet every day
it's public it's free produced by Noah
for everybody to use right I think it's
amazing but I don't know if anybody's
ever used it before see this one usually
no but ok I'm still going to go through
it it's a giant raster every day about
2.7 gigs of the nighttime lights for
every pixel on the planet and so if I
were to ask you how would you determine
if the pixels are actually zero if
there's actually zero light on the
planet if note since nobody's ever work
to the data i'm just going to answer so
I'm not going to wait for an answer what
actually happens is that there are two
types of zeroes on that data set ones
are actually yes for the month there was
no light observed right what for that
day the other is that there was cloud
cover for that day which means we
couldn't see what the light underneath
it was and if you didn't know you would
just put the two together and that's an
important distinction for any product
you work on and beers again I like
obscure format so QR code again if
anybody wants to check out that data set
and last one a survey of income and
program participation does anybody ever
heard of this one it's sip for short
basically it measures income for the
nation so you might have not have heard
of sip but you've probably seen it in
the news particularly recently about the
income of our nation how families are
doing house how households are doing you
seen it probably in reports I know I
have and sometimes it drives me crazy
because you will not believe the amount
of times I've seen people take sip
panels and not wait them and so for
people who aren't familiar with sort of
methodology I'm sorry
I am so I work a lot of senses so it
just comes with the job if you don't
wait it you're not waiting against the
population you're not working making the
estimates cohesive and comparable right
cross longitudinal cross-sectional
doesn't work you cannot put those
numbers by themselves just doesn't work
and so again anybody wants to check that
out I'm going to tell you right now all
of these websites they look pretty bad
so it's typical federal government
websites forgive us but the information
there is important if you're going to
use this to build a product it's
important if you're going to use this to
drive and insight it's important so
again the question I'm asking is how do
we convey the necessary information to
use our product to use the inheritance
we give you and just liven things up I
have an anecdote about myself and how I
missed sort of understood the data so
the veers data set we I talked about
earlier before we were trying to build
well I'll just make it I so the Royal we
I was trying to build and tie that much
sensor data to economic activity right
and what that would imply is that if we
could derive a relationship we could
generate a sensor built economic
indicator which is huge our indicators
in the economy are sent survey driven
our admin record driven which is
completely dependent on budget you can't
really stop a satellite once you launch
it which is the best part
so I took that beers data I took all the
accounting hitters all the demographics
and I counted for a population accounted
for all that stuff you know all the
typical gambit and I was like yes I know
what I'm doing I'm an adult I deserve to
do this this is important what I forgot
is that the earth that we live on is a
sphere and that's important why because
it turns out when you take an image of a
sphere places higher or further from the
equator have lower pixel count and so
you're essentially sampling less at
higher latitudes and so that messed my
whole analysis up simple simple
observation right i mean i'm not a
flatter first so i know that it is a
sphere but i just forgot I just assumed
that was something that didn't apply to
me so that leads me to this tendency but
i think i have and i don't know if
everybody else shares which is that
there's this innate behavior within us
to think if we silo ourselves from the
data we're from the domain from that
information it protects us that somehow
ignorance is bliss and you've seen these
cases they're not they can destroy what
you've worked so hard for it and so the
statement i really want to give today is
that sort of real insights and real
outcomes can only come when we truly
synthesize both the knowledge we have
with the data and the mechanics of that
data which i'll leave too much more
intelligent people today to talk about
but it doesn't come for free you can hat
you can't have one without the other to
build something real um
just a little plug on our end at
commerce so what are we doing about it
we have a couple ideas I have a couple
ideas the one we've launched so far is
the well before that I think the root of
that is that it's a communication
problem it's a communication / education
problem what do I mean by that the the
core function is that how do we as the
people transmitting that data providing
it and the people inheriting that data
communicate right right now it's in a
weird badly built website that you have
to know about where we have a number you
could call it who calls people right
like you know so at the heart of it is
is there a way for us to do that better
three machines right make it machine
readable so that's automatic is there a
way to incorporate that into the
analysis automatically so that you avoid
that pitfall these are all questions
were asked one of the solutions we have
is just plugging my own product is the
data usability project it has tutorials
with actual live code again a QR code
because I like QR codes if you're
interested but I just want to skip over
that and oh before I skip over that we
have tutorials on all these things you
know business dynamics all that stuff
written Python there's a library both
feel free to check it out but what I
really let the do is pose this question
everybody here who works with data in
very diverse ways and love to hear what
you think and just to reiterate no
really I would really love to hear what
you think of how to answer this problem
um and please contact me if you do so
hopefully a little white link aim if not
you know we're sort on our path where
the body dama under the tree you know
gaining enlightenment nobody gets a
reference good okay I'm done
super gay feel like a stand-up comic
I Detroit looking really weird and
within the usual way so but that's off
the top my head I haven't thought about
it in a while so we are continuing to
work on it so it is a work in progress
but that problem has been overcome there
are obviously others questions
uh yeah I can talk a little bit about
that so we have do have on teams and all
the agencies trying to rebuild those
websites you know at least in bootstrap
or something you know that makes it like
a little bit modern um but that the
court the court issue i think is that it
doesn't solve the problem of people
knowing where to get that information
right is there someone who can include
it in the data or it's part of the data
that you can't do something that breaks
it you know I'm I have no idea so but
these are all thoughts we're having any
questions you mean like that's that's
funny we actually have a website called
the most wanted datasets which is what
we think our datasets that are cool then
nobody uses um I wish I had put that URL
in the presentation right now but I
think off the top of my head a cool one
is dmsp which is again a satellite
product but it has a long history those
satellites have been going on since I
believe like 2005 and so you have a long
time series of pictures of the planet
every month which i think is pretty cool
yeah question over here or something
yes so that's actually a really astute
observation is there like a feedback
loop that we're building in right is
there like a network with developing of
users of our data and we're all trying
to do that I mean like there's obviously
a lot of 3rd platform options to you
know like that have this public data
available but also try to build that the
our products are sort of separated into
two group users core which is the
historical users that were this data was
congressionally mandated for so like
census is mandated for congressional
districts right so that's the that's the
core user everybody else's cake you know
ACS is a supplement so so that's just
part of it the traditional users do you
have a feedback mechanism they they're
heavily invested you know and they
constantly are invited they talk back
and everything but that's pretty like a
personal relationship our new users we
do want to build that community that
currently we do not have that and that
is something we want to work on if you
have thoughts yeah please
last one oh yeah okay so the question
was is there a way to I believe correct
me if I'm wrong build like sort of a
product that is a date microservice
instead of just a bulk release or an
open release and there are we do have
pockets like that rims is one people pay
for it in a consistent basis are like
foreign trade is a subscriber service
actually people subscribe to that data
and we have a they have a large customer
component like customer service
component for that data set
unfortunately for the vast majority of
public data sets they are bulk release
and they are not consistent and part of
the reason for that is because they're
built towards certain users like I
mentioned before the primary user that
was this data was meant for and so
unfortunately like for doee it's an ins
if I'll it's probably an excel file I'm
guessing and so it's built for like
policy people so they're like that's the
most are going to get you can't give
them a JSON they will freak out you know
i sent a just an anecdote again i sent a
markdown file once to a policy person
and they sent back they couldn't open it
and so I was like but you're you're
supposed to be in charge of tech policy
you know but I'm not going to name names
but I got into a lot of trouble for that
one but yes you're absolutely right like
the idea that are our values in a
surface is absolutely something we
should think about unfortunately a lot
of our data has to be free we can't and
to build that dynamic on basically a
congressional budget line is much harder
you know we give when we can't charge so
it's something we're thinking about yeah
so we've open source definitely
yeah well there were questions I just
wanna give a pokemon my friend Rebecca
up there I think right is that you
Rebecca I love you spoilers but yeah
thank you very much